researchers used high-speed cameras to
study frog muscles and the slowed down
video helps reveal secrets of the frogs
jumping abilities the researchers from
Brown University studied the video frame
by frame the videos you're seen were
shot at 500 frames per second before the
frogs jump they stretch most of their
hind limb muscles and increase their
length which may be part of their secret
the Brown University research paper
published recently in the Proceedings of
the Royal Society be focused on
bullfrogs but other frogs were filmed
with high-speed cameras as well
revealing stunning video of the
amphibians ability to jump here the
champion jumper a Cuban tree frog is
seen as muscle stretch contract and then
stretch again at the height of its jump
the frog jump has three simultaneous
movements the forelegs flex the hind leg
swings to a vertical position and locks
and the thigh swings in a horizontal
plane some bullfrogs which average about
seven inches in length have been
recorded jumping as much as seven feet
that's more than ten times their length
the study focused on the plantaris
muscle a smaller leg muscle researchers
implanted sensors and electrodes on the
plantaris to gather data
lead researcher Manny Azizi says a
conclusion from the study is the frogs
muscles have tremendous passive
flexibility unlike mammals whose muscles
are mostly stiff the frogs generate a
ton of mechanical energy during their
jumps Azizi says the frogs are in some
ways cheating the limits of what muscles
alone should be capable of doing the
Frog first stretches most of its hind
limb muscles while in a crouching
position making the muscles longer so
they can produce much more force that
force is what propels them into the air
the frog's secret trick to get past the
law of physics just might be the ability
to use their very stretchy muscles to
create a force of nature that no mammal
four-legged or human can even come close
to
you